how's it going bros my name is welcome
to three free games yeah that's it first
game is Sakura clicker the Don't Tell
might SIA
[Music]
yeah yeah ah man yeah whoa I just click
this is the greatest game of all time
what is what is this what even I I don't
understand I have so many questions all
right I just mom mom please don't look
at me don't look at me right now mom I'm
better than this just keep clicking what
am i doing to them what happens to them
do they like it or do they just like it
I can't tell
instead of bad in or a good day yeah
that could be both is it pain or sexual
yeah it never stops I feel so guilty
okay so I can buy I buy that if I will
ever level it while leveling up holy
crap I'm wrecking these hoes oh how many
of these women is in the desert how can
there be so many in the desert there's
way too many ones in the desert I didn't
go four years in college for this
she said hentai look at this one shot
one shot one shot one shot one shot
I am the best Sakura clicker of all time
she's just standing there like no no
[ __ ] given ever save an exit best game
best game best game best game i have
ever gamed in my entire guy game game i
was a video game i would be inside that
if i was a video game i want to be
sakura sakura click sakura quicker
favorite game I will I will Jess best
game
[Music]
I know what you're thinking there's no
way there's no way there's just no way
he can find a better game than Sakura
clickers welcome to the photo pie
Channel ladies and gentlemen we have
always a better game there we go
welcome to Logan Kart 8 the [ __ ] was
that
okay here we go crappy random stages
that nobody wants to play cup Edwin's
fum alright so here I am is Logan man
very there we go of course ultimate
speed this is really cool what are they
doing
hello sonic how you doing my man damn it
good soundtrack very nice steering [ __ ]
you sanic the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing
oh god no not that the thing take this
[ __ ] that's right I'm from the
hood [ __ ] this is my favorite racing
game of all chat [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's right Sonic eat a dick come on
come on you piece of [ __ ] come on [ __ ]
you I'm [ __ ] Logan this greatest game
of all time okay let's try this again
but I see speedy
you mean sanic we can do this brush come
on we got a [ __ ] sanic what the [ __ ]
was that
okay go sanic holy [ __ ] boy oh my god oh
god yes from red shells what a scrub he
wasted them all holy [ __ ] I got this
yeah go sanic my boy go sanic oh no
[ __ ] ah what is even that whoa ah yeah
hit me up with that sweet tune
hmm yeah ah so good
speedy got number one whoa there is hope
my children
shoot it what is going on help help
yes I'm number one yeah fresh game doing
real good boy come on last lap no we
can't [ __ ] no no no no no damn it go
sanic okay what happened yes oh I never
been this happy in my entire life look
at this yeah I feel pretty good about
that one I see a lot of comments say
like oh he has the most subscribers but
he's not even good at games excuse me do
you have you like watched me play this
no [ __ ] you
[Music]
if you need help you're [ __ ] well that
lets say you know it's a PewDiePie game
right there that [ __ ] is this
sorry hey sorry to keep you am I
supposed to talk over this starting to
keep you waiting [ __ ]
welcome to the world of Pokemon my name
is dick people call me [ __ ] a professor
this world is inhabited by creatures we
call dicks people in dicks live this is
such a powerful story that really speaks
to me but we don't know everything about
the day yeah now go and suck a dick
thank you thank you so much am i growing
weed oh look that weed here take one of
these rare Pokemon all right I'll go
middle first time I played I pick
squirtle so I'll go squirtle the guy
passed out over here
I shouldn't have smoked that we'd leave
me alone I'm trying to take a piss great
all right our first Pikmin
I mean jacket battle Jesus [ __ ] Christ
is I don't think that go my dick rekt
the what I will I will fight do it
tailwhip I should die like instantly my
dick fainted what happened to Pokemon
alright I don't I don't remember it like
this let's try and go somewhere else see
if we can find some lighter Pokemon
there we go maybe we're like Iraq that
our some [ __ ] there you go we can [ __ ]
this hose up go my dick [ __ ] their level
14 how might our fantastic fantastic
yeah just just keep doing it how is how
is this a game Eamon I just keep losing
40 bucks this is [ __ ]
this is quality how about we just go
here our first battle hi I like shorts
they're comfy nice aware
[Music]
okay here we go Prez this is that yeah
he sent out in a bitch-ass rat attack
it's level [ __ ] 11 now am i ah [ __ ] me
I'm gonna die look at this this is not
fair
run cat dammit what's the point is this
gonna [ __ ] me and I'm gonna lose 40
bucks again
hello I'm [ __ ] I specialize in turning a
pro Cornish if you like I can convert
one of yours into a pile of [ __ ] come
back when you have a nap record this is
just art isn't it let's just go and
collect a nap record and I am hopefully
and these trainees have some all right
which ones are hyper corns are you a nap
record no are you an epic or there's no
APRA corns is it no well [ __ ] you then
Jesus Christ what's the [ __ ] point
all right whoa what is this oh my god
I'm gonna get a pile of [ __ ] again do
you have an African yes I do
yes I'll turn your be LK APRA corn into
a pile of [ __ ] for you it should be
finished you know what I'm just gonna
end it here I don't know what else to do
here but with that note will I have to
end it there Rose thank you so much for
watching this video and all my videos
for that matter it really means a lot
hit like if you enjoyed and I'll see you
in the next one as always stay awesome
bros it's in your life
[Music]
yes okay this is a pretty solid bridge I
would say so now we build the land